john sparks report now from the city
contains video showing the aftermath of
the attack
it sits on the grass outside the station
in kramertorsk
the remnants of a ballistic missile its
work already done
and on the side there is a message
zadeti or done for the children
a message of revenge it seems sprayed in
white
this weapon was aimed at the only place
in this embattled city where large
groups were gathering
the train station was packed with people
trying to find a way out some four
thousand waiting for trains heading to
western ukraine
they were running from the russian
military but this brutal war came to
them
you can't unsee scenes like these
neither can you forget the sound
[Applause]
high explosives and bits of shrapnel
tearing through passengers waiting for a
train
how many dead bodies and the children
the children says one
the authorities say at least 50 people
were killed including five children
more than a hundred have been
[Music]
we were in this booking hall a couple of
days ago and it was full it was full of
people and their
their personal possessions as they
waited to board trains out on
the platform and there was a singer a
famous singer who stood there at the
doors and he sang to everybody and they
were
they were tearful as they they boarded
trains for lev and now
bags
without their owners left
in the middle
of the hall
i hear phones ringing friends and loved
ones trying to contact them
[Music]
the station manager stayed in post when
the missile struck
and she was still fielding inquiries
when we arrived
this man was looking for his mother
he could see her bag but he didn't know
where she was
the casualties were taken to area
hospitals and at city hospital number
three some had to wait in the halls
there's a war on and they don't have the
staff or the beds
outside friends and loved ones waited
for news
this woman's son had been caught in the
blast and was undergoing surgery
a seventeen-year-old called nastia have
been waiting for the train to keep busy
naturally
can you
describe for us what happened what you
saw
russia denies all responsibility
suggesting ukraine bombed its own
station adding it doesn't use missiles
of this type
these assertions are widely disputed and
deeply resented in ukraine whose
president called this an act of evil
john sparks sky news in kramatorsk